ことです始めた上で皆さん口癖ってありますでしょうかたぶん僕を無意識にあると思う
んですけども僕だったら例えば何か食べたときにちょっとっていう言葉なかっ付がちな
んですよなんねすごいいろんなことがちょっとになってしまうこういう口癖があります
世の中にはいろんな人がいるのでいろんな口癖があると思うんですけどもあの私の後輩
の健介という音方がおりまして
との後の口癖がちょっとねあの
ちょっと変なんですよどう変化そう言いますと言板の何がコットすごいとは強い
なんか素敵と言いたい時にならずさあも何か言いたいことの前に一番
をつけてしまうどうなるかといいますと一番すごいと一気ランカッコイイとかこれが
一番おいしいとあらゆるものが一番
あらゆるものがナンバーワンになってしまうで彼が何か食べるためにや
一番おいしい磯田ついカレー食べたら一番美味しいって彼の中の1位の変動が
ものすごいんですよどうなっているんだと愛とちょっとインチを甘く見すぎている
そんな何でもかんでも一番一番です全部一番つけてると物事の差がつかなくて金はいつ
かパンクしてしまうと思うんですよねほんと物事の本質の
一番を見極めてもらえないのでちょっとポッパー線的な簡単に一番一番別か言って
ほしくないんでいくつとこれヤラセじゃないんですけども普通に何気なく日常を後輩と
の日常を動画で撮るので1時間ほど撮ってみてなんか行かれが普通の生活の中で一番
なり何っていうことを使うとか突っ込みていこうと思いますでは vtr
どうぞよ
って全然で作っても目が立っ
不ランプ
一番健康的いう
にケーキ食べたいっ
パフィ利益パンケーキ者や一般形だですこれ
一番美味しかったします
5人たちなんですかだめじゃんちゃんぽんてラーメンでございます
もうなんです
ここピース
が一番十分なメカ付
[音楽]
ん
んん
ます
ん
一番まあか今ません
ぐっもーにん
お兄やっぱね最強に結局ごはん食べたかったから
のが一番ちょうどいいいっ
退け米よね
一番前うんレイラ一番前
生まれるよねー米が一番前あいつはお前なぁ
[音楽]
ん
プップッ
[音楽]
どうすか6番満開ございます
だろうな上げすけ
米が一番おねえ
キュッ
[音楽]
いつもお腹いっぱい
ドンが一番お腹いっぱい
いとなり全員動くわけじゃなくて大イカのアタリ行かないためで酷いな
さては一番使え例えばなぜも勝てませんね
デビューで証明
沿いではゴーストシップ
はっはっはいやーだろうね上けどね
またモールねー
ポイントってこれ強いもしかして釣りだって主人公ねっております
主人公の一番最高なって坊
ですが入っ金を外れてない一番強いですか
えっ
せますね
いやいいジョイゼリー周遊路うまく一番てくれてますね
おいはっはー
一般3人丸い繊細これさんではん
4日
さてさては例えばで face ますか
ては優ん
一番良い
すごいすべくられているやめてやめてやめて
あれパーン
[拍手]
2一番弱いが一番強いで昇格あっ
乗ってっ一番強いんとこ1枚はよろしいですね頑張っていきますはーい
twice 5位立っ
しまったのしーこれ一番楽しいがこれが俺の s roo
膳所使っ
残したというかかあさんお大事に使える打ち論でいますからちょっと待ってん
甘い地分前でこれが待ってた
[音楽]
うちは前行っ
てくと9 muses ティックトックあっ
web ずバナナん
自分もなくですっ
パンケーキだけです
[音楽]
うわぁ者ばそうかもいますよ
家をしないとっ
[音楽]
おっぱい女糞でかいっ
一番好き秋人であーた奇跡が生え航路 as well
一番パリでは恋すると思っただけでええ
すごい
一般店の cm 読もう
いやこれも椿でしょもう一番線するこれで5は探されたなぁこれは鬼没ロスレスで凄い
きれい
走ってみて誰チャンス
行く当分行け区東部頭の一番分
アイテムで減税なぁ
今日の動画ですね最近天井が何かあるたびにかなりのコール別で一番でつけるチェック
できる転生をやっておりました
動画はして約5時間ねぇものすごい数が10000を使ってぺナンバーワンが
ものすごい東れてるわけですよ
ナンバーワンが変動するんですよ唯一無二いってもなかったやラバーけっけ
えっまあまあ
女だあああああ1番菜波
葉を一枚一枚売れないっていうけど旅立ば上災難だある宿もっとが z 1確かに
助けるで今日一番つ今日は同一だけっ
説教だ
[音楽]
me
バッハ